JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Hi, everyone.
We have Audu in the house.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDU MAIKORI: Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: So
welcome, once again, to Google.
AUDU MAIKORI: Thank you.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
And welcome particularly
to Talks at Google.
It's really great
to have you here.
AUDU MAIKORI: It is an honor.
I'm shaking.
I'm really-- I've never
had a Google talk before.
So this is exciting.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Well, it's
being watched by
the whole world.
AUDU MAIKORI: Wow.
Hi, world.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
So you're very welcome.
AUDU MAIKORI: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: We're
focusing our discussion today
on redefining leadership through
music and entrepreneurship.
And I'm going to
start by just reading
a few lines from your
profile, and then we'll
get into the conversation.
AUDU MAIKORI: OK.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
So Audu Maikori
is a Nigerian lawyer,
entrepreneur, social activist,
public speaker, creative
industry professional, founder
and president of the Chocolate
City Entertainment Group.
Maikoro is also well-known in
Nigeria as a former "Nigerian
Idol" judge and
has been compared
to Simon Cowell due to his
tough stance on contestants
during auditions.
Maikori's Chocolate City is
arguably one of the biggest
record labels in Africa.
I think that deserves
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDU MAIKORI: Thank you.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Helping to guide and manage
the careers of several artists,
including Femi Kuti, MI,
Ice Prince Zamani,
Victoria Kimani, Asa,
Jesse Jagz, Nosa, Brymo,
Koker, Dice Ailes, et cetera.
A multi-award-winning
entrepreneur
and creative
industry specialist,
Maikori soon took on the
role of social activism
by funding and participating in
a variety of youth empowerment
projects.
He was a key member of the
Enough Is Enough rally in 2010,
which was aimed at
addressing poor governance
issues in Nigeria, during which
he had a face-off with Nigerian
military police, when he refused
to back down when a rifle was
pointed at him in a bid
to stop him from leading
the peaceful protest to the
gates of the National Assembly.
Maikori received a special
judge's commendation
at the finale of the
international young music
entrepreneur of the year, where
he beat nine other countries
to win the global
award in June 2007.
In 2011 and 2015,
he was recognized
by the "CityPeople Magazine"
for his outstanding contribution
to the Nigerian music industry.
Once again, welcome, Audu.
AUDU MAIKORI: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
You've had
quite an interesting career--
started life as a lawyer,
and then went on
to set up a very
successful, one of the most
successful record labels
in Africa.
I can understand the
transition in terms
of-- because besides
the glamor, there's
a lot of contracting,
intellectual property rights,
and all of that involved
in running a record label.
But you could have done
a number of things.
You could have set up your
own legal practice, et cetera.
Why music?
AUDU MAIKORI: Well, I did set up
my own legal practice, indeed,
before Chocolate
City even started.
I think for me, one of the
things that I've always
been kind of guided by is
the need to improve things.
Because I kind of think that
you're put on this Earth
to leave the Earth
better than you found it.
So if there's a problem, it's
not about complaining about it.
It's about doing something
about that problem.
And one thing that I saw
was that I was interacting
with a lot of creative people.
I found out that
they had-- I keep
telling this story
about a guy who
had a contract that had no
expiration date, no termination
date.
So I started getting
involved in promoting them,
and I just thought, OK.
There's a problem.
Maybe you need to set up
something that is the solution.
And that is what
kind of informed
registering Chocolate
City, getting a team,
and then trying to
change and kind of raise
the standards in terms
of how those are managed.
And then, of course,
the legal background
helped to put things in
proper perspective, as well.
So that's the story.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
And a lot of people have ideas
and also have an ambition
to transition either
from what they studied
or where they started
life out, et cetera.
But not many people successfully
make that transition.
How did you develop yourself?
What are the things
you had to learn
to be able to step into the role
of running a successful record
label?
AUDU MAIKORI: Well, for any
lawyer that's out there,
I always tell people,
like my father told me
before-- my father said to me
before that law is probably
one of the greatest
professions you can read simply
because it gives
you the dexterity
to work in almost any field.
So you're right
that whether it be
music or movies or the
whole creative sector,
there's clearly a place for
lawyers to be part of that
because the whole thing
about intellectual property
is a set of rights and how those
rights are controlled, managed,
and exploited.
So everything cuts across,
whether it be software,
whether it be--
even Google itself
has a set of different rights.
It's creative ideas.
So lawyers fit into almost
every sphere of human endeavor.
But you're right that there
was no blueprint, so to speak,
because when I started, one
of the things that we noticed
was that, OK, so
there's a lot of talent.
And it seemed that all
the talent was in Lagos.
But we found out that
most of the talent
actually migrated to Lagos
because the infrastructure
wasn't there elsewhere.
And one of the things
that we set out to do
was start off in the north.
So we started of in Abuja
and tried to defy those odds.
So we've been in business
for about 11 years now.
For the first seven or eight
years, we were in Abuja.
So everything we did was in
Abuja, actually, which I think
is phenomenal
because what it did
now was begun to change
people's mindsets about what
the creative sector was in
that part, which is generally
considered a bit more
conservative than Lagos.
So what did I do?
One of the books that was
quite influential to me
was "How I Lost My Virginity."
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Richard Branson.
AUDU MAIKORI: Richard Branson.
It's a great book.
I recommend it to
anybody out there
who wants to try
something a bit different.
I think it was the daring of it.
It was the fact
that somebody who
seemed to have all
the disadvantages
turned them around,
which kind of
speaks to the power of the
mind, that if you can think it
and you can believe it
and keep believing it,
it's a matter of time.
It will happen.
So that was my mentor.
And in 2011, I actually
got to meet him.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Oh fantastic.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
So it was like, wow.
I mean, I was reading
about this guy,
and then, hey, I'm
shaking hands with him.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR: And
you were inspired by him.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
And then we got a
chance to speak.
And I asked him a few questions
about his business and et
cetera.
And it's just a testament that
if you think about it long
enough and you work hard
towards it, it's possible.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
That's fantastic.
Do you have other mentors?
AUDU MAIKORI: Yes.
I have two other mentors.
One of them is Mr.
Hakeem Belo Osagie,
who happens to be the
chairman of my company.
And the reason why--
it's not because he's
the chairman of the
company, actually.
It's not that.
It's the fact that you rarely
find people who are as educated
but as humble as,
easy to relate with.
And he likes young
people, for some reason.
So he's always trying to
encourage and help that.
But it's even the
most strategic lessons
in terms of how to
deal with business
and how to think on a global
scale that is inspiring.
But my number mentor, my
father, [INAUDIBLE] Maikori.
He's a lawyer, as well.
And he literally taught
us everything we knew.
So go and read.
What's your focus?
What's your plan?
Oh, you like music.
Here's a keyboard and
a teacher you wanted.
So anything that he
thought we were--
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Capable of.
AUDU MAIKORI:
Capable or interested
in, he would invest in
it and say, go ahead.
So I paint.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Oh, do you?
Wow.
AUDU MAIKORI: Was, I am.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: OK.
I'm not sure a lot of
people know that about you.
AUDU MAIKORI: Many people don't.
But I paint.
I write poetry.
I'm a bit of a
creative person myself.
But that's also
because my family.
My father was in the choir.
My mother was in the choir.
And so what I know about
music was taught primarily
between my father and my mother.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
AUDU MAIKORI: So they're
the reason I'm here.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
That's great.
Do you sing?
AUDU MAIKORI: Nope.
No.
And that's why I
had to-- you see,
that's the overall
reason why I had
to do the label because
I knew I had no hope.
So I just had to invest--
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Support the other--
AUDU MAIKORI: Exactly,
the real talent, yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
In addition to the book
you talked about,
"Losing My Virginity,"
are there other books
that have really
had a profound impact on you?
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
One other book is "The
48 Laws of Power."
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Ah, yes.
AUDU MAIKORI: Now, when
people hear that, they always
say, oh, politics, it's
evil, and things like that.
But really, what
it teaches you is
about human psychology,
understanding people,
understanding how
to do business.
So one of the most
important lessons
I learned from that book
was that always appeal
to people's self-interest.
So people are not
interested in you.
So don't fool yourself.
Don't think that it's about you.
It's about them.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: You're
only under the illusion.
AUDU MAIKORI: So once
you know what they want,
then you're in business, and
you can offer that to them.
Then you have the
common ground to speak.
Another book is "The Tipping
Point" by Malcolm Gladwell.
Another book is "Blink" by
Malcolm Gladwell, as well.
And then there's the "Outliers,"
by Malcolm Gladwell again.
And what I like about his
books is that he's analytical.
He looks at a pure
set of ordinary facts.
Then he's able to now dig
deep and try to draw some--
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Parallels.
AUDU MAIKORI: Exactly, from
them and just kind of expand it.
Another book is called--
do I need to go on?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: No, yes.
Yes, sure.
Maybe one more.
AUDU MAIKORI: OK, one more.
So my favorite
fiction book is a book
called "Keep the Aspidistra
Flying" by George Orwell,
the guy that wrote
"Animal Farm."
And it's a story about a guy
whose mental state made him
a poor person.
So it's a guy who had all
the opportunity in the world
to become a success.
But he was shying
away from success
because he wasn't sure
he could handle it.
And it's that progression
between making up
your mind that look,
I'm ready, and how
he progressed to success.
So it's an amazing book.
Many people do not know
about it because it's
one of those not very
well-known books.
But it's a great book to read.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Great.
Now, talking a bit more
about Chocolate City,
you've been great at
identifying talent.
What would you say are the
two to three essential things
in identifying talent
within the music industry?
AUDU MAIKORI: Well, I must
say that the industry is
changing quite rapidly, just
like any other industry.
And the ways by which
you identify talent now
have kind of greatly
changed and expanded.
But I think that the first thing
is the raw, natural talent.
But the second thing, which
is even more important
than talent, is the mindset.
It's the readiness to go
out of your comfort zone
and to be critiqued, to
be in a difficult place,
to go out and just
risk being embarrassed
and come back with
either a yea or a nay,
but being able to go
back and keep going on.
So a resilient,
perserverant spirit.
The third thing would be just
the distinctness of the talent
because I think that
people, we want different.
We want fresh.
We want new.
You can't sound
like Michael Jackson
and then hope to be the
next Michael Jackson.
You're just gonna be a
Michael Jackson wannabe.
So originality, distinctness,
and your uniqueness, for me,
is very, very important.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Great.
And when you identify
those things,
how do you then
take the raw talent
and transform that into
a successful artist?
Because Chocolate
City has been quite
successful at actually
developing talent
in a really big way.
And if we think about
any organization,
really, for you to
be able to produce
positive results on
an ongoing basis,
that doesn't happen by accident.
It's about culture.
It's about a number of things.
So what are the
dynamics that have
been built into the organization
to make that possible?
AUDU MAIKORI: Well,
I always tell people
that most people think
Chocolate City is a label.
And I told them right
from the beginning
that it's not a label.
It's an idea company, simple.
So we're very creative, and
we understand creatives,
and we want to be able to
allow them to be themselves.
So an artist doesn't
become more talented
because he signed on a label.
He just simply has
more opportunities
to exploit and explore
that talent beyond what he
had before.
So what we try to
do is keep a balance
between what the label wants
and the creative expression
of the artists.
Very important.
The second thing is that
we've actually built
a very detailed structure.
And I don't know that many that
have the structure we've built.
So we have a proper board.
We have a proper team.
We have an A&R department.
We have the studios.
We have the guys who
do the licensing.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Governance.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
We've tried to develop
an ecosystem such
that we can take care of most of
the things of a budding artist.
But of course,
the other thing is
being able to build those
relationships, as well,
valuable relationship, like
with Google and YouTube
and being able to kind
of have this conversation
to help us scale and
to improve what we've
been doing over the past years.
So I'll say it's that.
But over and above
all that is that
the artist-label relationship
is a very interesting
relationship.
It's a marriage that almost from
this point where you say, I do,
you don't.
You know?
And that's simply because
the objectives are the same,
but the perspectives
are different.
Now, unless you
have an alignment
of those perspectives,
you may think that you're
going different ways.
So, for example,
the artist may feel
that he looks really beautiful
as a man in a yellow skirt.
That's his creative expression.
We think not because we
look at the cultural context
and know that it
wouldn't fly here.
So it's that
discussion and agreeing
on the fact that, look, you
need to make money, man.
And it's that communication and
putting those things together
that make the difference
in the success
or failure of an artist.
And you can't
over-emphasize the need
for a real team around
talent because, like I said,
the talent didn't become more
talented when he got signed.
He had more talent to
help his talent seem more
talented that he was before.
So that's the only difference.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
And I think those can be applied
to really any organization.
AUDU MAIKORI: Anything, yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
The power
of having the right team,
strategy, understanding
the market and what would
work in a market, those kinds
of things.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: So
it's been a success story.
But I'm sure you've had a number
of challenges along the way.
AUDU MAIKORI: Of course.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
What's been your toughest
day on the job, so to speak?
AUDU MAIKORI: Toughest day
of the job is every week.
It's every week.
I think with every
business, you do
have your peculiar
challenges that reoccur.
I think the biggest
challenge that we
face most times is an
alignment of perspective.
I think it's the
biggest challenge.
And if you look
at all businesses,
it's really about that.
It's that there's a
communication dissonance.
So it's the case
of the elephant.
You're looking at the
behind of the elephant.
You're like, wow,
round and bumpy.
Somebody's looking at the
front, and they say, oh, big
ears and a long tail.
So it depends on what
you're looking at.
But when we're able to all go
around the elephant and see it,
then we have a better chance
at resolving the issue.
And it's always going to
be part of that process
because when you
think about strategy--
and I'll give you a
couple of instances.
So there've been
singles that we've
released that I
personally-- I'll
call three or the artists, so
with MI, Ice Prince, and Brymo.
So after we released
Brymo's first single,
we had a choice between
releasing the second single,
whether it was going
to be "Ara" or it
was going to be "Good Morning."
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Right.
AUDU MAIKORI: So I
thought "Good Morning"
was a more phenomenal song.
And the other guys thought
"Ara" was bumpy and everything.
And I didn't disagree.
I just simply said,
I thought it would
be great to put
out "Good Morning."
And then when they're like,
what is this [INAUDIBLE]?
So what did we do?
We have our team.
So we sat on a team, 13 or
14 of us, and we said, OK.
Let's do a listening session.
So we listened to the song.
And for the artist,
he didn't mind.
But he liked "Ara."
So we sat down,
everybody said "Ara."
So we said, let's go with "Ara."
And it was the right call.
But we also had some of those
sections that we all said, no.
This is the song.
So "Oleku," for example,
which is probably
one of Ice's biggest
songs to date, which
was a phenomenal song
because it was probably
one of most remixed songs,
as well, across the continent
was that the original
version was ready early 2010.
When it was sent
to me, I liked it,
but I thought that there was
some production errors in it.
So there are places where the
kicks weren't loud enough.
And there were places where
there was no-- now, with music,
I don't know how to use
the words to describe it.
But I just know
what it sounds like.
So there are parts where
the music needed to stop.
So if I played both the
original and the final one,
you'd understand what
I'm talking about this.
But the artist didn't get it.
He's just gonna
put out his single.
I said, no.
It's not ready.
And so we couldn't
find [INAUDIBLE]
who produced that
song in maybe 30,
20-something minutes to do
the song because he was away
recording somewhere else.
So I called MI and a guy called
[INAUDIBLE] who is his manager,
and said, you guys
need to do this, that,
and described the parts.
And they said, OK.
Fine.
And they went in, and
they worked on it.
Now to show you the difference
between those two songs,
I took the song originally to
a radio station, a top radio
station here.
And I played it for
one of the A&Rs there.
She's a radio host, but
she's also great A&R.
And she listened to it and
said, this song's just OK,
but that she didn't
really feel it.
So when we did the
remix, the other version,
she said-- so after
playing it, she said,
oh, this song is fantastic!
So I said, but
can't you remember,
I brought this same song
to you a few months ago?
I was like, wow.
Now, was that the same song?
But it wasn't that the
beat had changed that much.
It was some small elements
that enhanced the production.
And so while we're delaying
for the song to come out,
it did work out
for good, as well.
Now, the last example
is a song called "Safe."
And when MI recorded
"Safe," "Safe"
was like a wordplay
on different songs.
So he Stole a bit from the most
popular songs around that time
and made a whole five
minute, 42 second song.
And so when you he playing it
for me, it wasn't danceable.
And it didn't sound like
people would bump to it.
But the flow was ridiculous.
It was immaculate.
So I said, you know,
it's a bit too long.
Why don't you cut it?
And he said, no.
Just leave it like that.
So we argued back and forth.
And he said, Audu,
how just trust me.
Just trust me.
So I said, OK.
Go ahead.
And that song actually
changed his career, as well.
So like I said,
it's those things.
It's actually the fights,
the disagreements,
and the alignments
that make a product.
And without that, you cannot
have a well-rounded product.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
That makes a lot of sense.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: You
talked about the technology
platforms like YouTube.
What role do you see technology
platforms, social media,
YouTube playing in the growth
of music industry and your work.
AUDU MAIKORI: No,
I mean, it is clear
that the music renaissance
that we're experiencing--
or, I think we're way
past a renaissance now.
We're in it now.
But what actually
catalyzed that was clearly
the internet and platforms
like YouTube, Google,
Facebook, and the rest.
And the reason was that we had
an equal, level playing field.
Whatever was happening
outside in the world,
we could also have
real-time access to that.
So we were not behind.
And I remember when I
was much younger, one,
you watched "Top of the Pops."
You're probably watching
"Top of the Pops"
that was two years old.
And you're excited about the
music you're listening to.
So you're behind stuff.
But now, as it's being released,
you can watch it in real time.
You can go and Google.
And one of the things I
love about Google-- and this
is not a Google
advert, by the way.
But one of the things I love
to on Saturdays, actually
listen to popular music
and then find the samples,
then go back and find the
original versions of the songs,
and then read up
on those artists
and find out what
inspired the song, what
parts were extrapolated,
and all those things.
And they help also
because most of them
were in the publishing
part of the company.
So it's important to know
where you can find a sample
or where you can clear a
sample, if the sample has
no copyright attached to it.
And so I'm saying that
because of that convergence,
people are now talking
more, sharing ideas faster.
And people are now
making covers of music.
So you go on Google, find a song
and all that-- or on YouTube,
sorry.
And you can search up
anything, and it pops up.
So you have immediate
information.
Now, there's no doubt that
the next phase for the music
industry is purely
going to be tech.
But now you're not going
to call it music and tech.
It's going to be a merger.
There'll be no difference
between those two.
I find that if
you look at what's
happening with the
trends in music,
people want a wider bouquet,
a repertoire of music
that they can access.
And they also want
to listen to what
they want to listen to when
they want to listen to it.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
And on any device.
AUDU MAIKORI: On any device.
So you sort off with your
table and go to your phone,
go to the car and all that.
So it's more about
the experience now.
And I think that technology is
indistinguishable from music
or from entertainment.
There's this whole
conversions of ICT, music,
and even the whole
experiential thing,
just knowing that you can
watch a concert live or stream
it or watch behind the
scenes [INAUDIBLE].
So I think that it's
now more about people
being immersed in the
experience and not just about,
oh, I'm listening to music.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
Certainly, I think
a lot of us are
very proud with the
explosion and the growth
within the music industry.
It's been a great way
to showcase Nigerian
and African culture and also to
export that through technology.
What factors would you say--
you mentioned technology as one.
But what other
factors would you say
have led to the
rapid growth we've
seen in the music industry
in terms of impact,
in terms of quality, as well?
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
The other day, somebody
sent me an article
that South Africa was asking
for 70% local content, sort
of a directive to all radio
stations in South Africa.
And the South African artists
were really excited about that.
And someone was
asking, you know,
it would be great if you
do something like that.
And I said, no.
Then many people forget
that Nigeria actually
had a local content policy
dating back over 10 years ago.
So without knowing it, that was
part of the reason why radio
stations now have to meet
that, comply with what
the [INAUDIBLE] class
incorporation had said,
which was that you need
to have at least 70%--
I think it was 80%,
actually-- local content.
So now you have to actually
look for that content to put.
And the more you
heard the music,
the more-- because remember that
radio's a very powerful thing.
The more you hear it,
the more you believe in.
The more you believe it, the
more you hear it and want more.
So that is a major part of that.
The second thing, also,
was that as access
to travel and the
economy also set in,
we began to look inwards.
So I'm thinking made in Nigeria.
But then again, the
internet and technology
helped to catalyze
or level the--
should I say the professional--
the quality of the sound.
So now we can learn how
to produce on YouTube.
There's a kid, I was
telling you earlier,
that you guys need to interview.
His name is [INAUDIBLE].
And I met him.
He's 16 and 1/2.
I met him two years ago,
when he was 16 and 1/2.
And his father took
me to his home studio.
So the guy said, oh,
he wanted to meet me.
He wanted to meet me.
So his father hounded me,
Audu, you need to hear my son.
And I just thought these parents
who-- everybody's son can sing.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Has talent,
AUDU MAIKORI: Everybody's
daughter and grandfather
can sing.
So--
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Just like all fathers
made first class in school.
AUDU MAIKORI: Exactly.
Everybody can sing.
But he sounded serious.
And he knew so much about the
music industry that I said, OK.
Let me go.
So I was on the
way to the airport.
And stopped by in this house.
It was in Abuja.
And the guy was
playing-- I was blown.
I've never heard
anything like that.
So I said, how old are you?
He said, 16 and 1/2.
I swore, there's no
way you can be 16.
He said, yes.
I said, so how do you
know how to produce?
He said, on YouTube.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
Fantastic, yeah.
AUDU MAIKORI: Do I
get a clap for that?
That was a nice slide in there.
But seriously, I was amazed.
And this is the point I'm
making, that the boy that's 16
is producing better than most
of the guys you hear now.
Now, imagine how many
other 16-year-olds.
And that is how the
quality of Nigerian music
also improved,
because people could
learn the tricks immediately
and begin to try them out.
The costs-- technology,
again, like I said,
is a big driver
because before, think
about the traditional
record labels.
You have to rent a big studio
like this, get live equipment,
get session men, book
the time that you
know that everybody's free, and
then they two, four, 10 takes.
And then you couldn't wipe it.
So you needed to
take the take again.
But now you can just
basically alter it with that
so the cost of production became
lower and more people could
come into the system and then
try out and be free with it.
So I think that's another one.
Then, of course, again,
technology, really,
because when you think
about DStv, Channel O, MTV
or any of these stations,
they are aided and abetted
by the fact that
there was access now
to that content that
wasn't there 30 years ago.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Yes, yes.
Absolutely, and
that's why we are
very passionate about
technology and the power
of digital platforms.
We know Nigerians are
very entrepreneurial.
They just need to have the
tools and the platforms.
So that's a great story
that you've shared.
We've seen other cases, as well,
of people learning a completely
new trade by watching
how-to videos on YouTube
or by consuming
information online.
And so we believe very
strongly in the power of that,
and it's exciting to see
some of the results that
are starting to show.
AUDU MAIKORI: It is.
And also, just know
that there was a time
I needed to try buying a car.
And you go to the
reviews and all that.
And then, I was like,
well, let's check Google.
So I googled the car.
And then I was able to-- there
was a video compared both
of the cars, the specs of them.
And it just showed me.
And I was able to make a
decision based on the fact
that I was practically
there, which is
what many people are not using.
They don't understand
there are other how-tos.
It's most about
music and lifestyle.
But over time.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: And do
you have any interest in movies
because there are
many similarities.
They're both audiovisual.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
So has that
ever-- is that
something that you're
likely to go into at some point?
Participate in the
Nollywood industry?
AUDU MAIKORI: Nollywood.
No, we're actually
working at that.
So just to kind of clarify,
we have a group of companies.
We have four companies.
One of them is a media
company, Chocolate City Media.
And we're really focused on
that over the past year or so.
And we've been working on
several interesting projects,
one of which is the
film [INAUDIBLE] which
we're working on.
And we're trying to build a
world-class film studio where
people can come in and
do some real film stuff
but also build a post-production
facility that is world class as
well as a training academy.
Because we think that
there's a skills gap.
I we think that you cannot
teach skills without
the infrastructure to
teach the skills in.
So people go for a
film course in Nigeria,
and there's no studio.
So how are you going to
learn how to do that?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
And practice?
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
So we are.
But apart from that,
we also have a movie.
We're done with the script now.
And it's going to be funny.
It's a music-- it's a comedy
based on the music industry.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Interesting.
AUDU MAIKORI: So you haven't
seen anything like it,
rest assured.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
When should we expect that?
Is that this year?
AUDU MAIKORI: I don't know.
I can't say that for sure.
But it's most likely that--
yeah, we're shooting this year.
But I'm not sure if we're
releasing it this year.
So watch this space.
I'll upload it on YouTube.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
How do you see
the music industry
evolving in the next decade?
AUDU MAIKORI: Here or globally?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
In Nigeria.
AUDU MAIKORI: I think we're
just coming into our own.
I think that there's a lot
of infrastructural things
have not been there.
And when I say that,
I'm talking more
about the intellectual
property part of it,
which is being able
to exploit the content
and really make money from it.
So yeah, we've seen a slew
of young people making
a lot of money off
music, but I still
think that it is
not an ecosystem.
I still think that the money
is stopping in some places
and is not being spread around.
The only way the
industry works is
if it services-- it has to
be a well-oiled machine.
So I see that there'll
be better enforcement
of intellectual property
rights, stronger copyright laws,
as well.
There are quite a few
reviews going on as we speak.
More skills
development-- more people
who are working on
sound engineering
as their only core
competence and not
just doing a bit of everything,
lighting and all those things.
So I think that with
those improvements,
you will see a lot more revenue
coming into the industry.
Price Waterhouse report
says that Nigeria
should be making
close to $100 million
annually just from
digital music by 2018.
But I think it's a very
conservative figure, very, very
conservative.
So
the potentials are enormous.
What we need to do,
however, is to be
able to ensure
there are people's
rights because intellectual
property is really everything.
And I'm not just speaking
because I'm a lawyer.
I'm saying, so you
invest in a product.
How do you ensure that
you're able to make money out
of that if your rights
can't be enforced.
So once we get that
done-- and there's
a lot we're doing, either
from the COSON, the Copyright
Society of Nigeria [INAUDIBLE].
We're talking with
the Senate, as well,
for regular legislative reviews.
We're also having industry
coalitions and saying,
we need to get better funding
for the corporate agencies.
Because once they have that
and they can crack down,
then you'll find there will
be a commensurate improvement
not just in the industry, but
even for the GDP of Nigeria.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Right.
Because piracy is a huge
challenge at the moment.
What's been your
proudest moment?
You talked about
challenges earlier.
What are some of the things that
you've been really proud of,
operating in the industry?
AUDU MAIKORI: Wow.
I think my the first
moment I was excited about
was when I heard the very
first artist we signed,
and I saw his video on the TV.
That was exciting.
The second, I
think, was probably
when I won the Global Award
for the British Council.
2011, we won something
called the African Awards
for Entrepreneurship.
And that was huge
because we applied
with 3,300 other applications
from around 48 countries
in Africa.
And we got shortlisted from
3,000 to 300 to 30 to 15,
then to top 10, and we
won the second prize.
That was huge.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
That's remarkable, yeah.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah,
that was huge for us.
And we're [INAUDIBLE].
We got nice check
with it, as well.
So--
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
That helped.
AUDU MAIKORI: That helped.
That really helped.
The third was when we also
opened our Kenyan office,
our inroad to East Africa.
And then, of course--
I mean, there
are many of those high points.
But for me, I would say that
the ultimate high point is
when I see these
artists that we found,
and we knew that they
didn't have anything.
And today, they come in and
say, oh, let me buy you this.
Come, let's go out.
And we enter their fancy
cars, and they're living well.
And for me, it's like,
wow, this transformation.
And it's good that they're also
carrying other people along.
For me, it's always
about each one build one,
and then we keep
making that happen.
And that's how growth happens.
So for me, that's
my proudest moment.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
That's great.
So I'm going to take some
questions from the audience
now.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah, so
remember that I'm a lawyer.
People seem to forget that.
But I spent quite a bit
of time in litigation.
And one of the things that
you find is-- and like I said,
the whole creative
sector is really
about intellectual property
rights, enforcement,
and exploitation.
And the question
really is that when
somebody breaches his
contract-- and the truth of that
is [INAUDIBLE] in time
or the other either party
or other artists
have not breached.
It's the readiness
to remedy the breach.
And in that situation,
what was happening
was that we had an
image crisis and a lack
of-- what's the word?
So we build a brand, and
we have an artist who
is promoting things that we're
against that and actually
were illegal under Nigerian
law, which is marijuana.
And we're saying, you can't
put these pictures out.
We can't promote this because
if affects not just your band
but ours by extension.
And then it makes us
lose business, as well.
So you can't do this.
And the artist says, no, we can.
I will.
So we say, fine.
We suspend your contract
because under the contract,
we can suspend you when
we find that you're
doing things that are
inimical to what will
help to push your business.
Remember, we've invested
millions of naira
in this brand, in
building this brand.
And I always like
to use the analogy
that if you took a
loan from a bank,
and you took 20 million
naira, and you're
going to build a
restaurant, and then
halfway, one of the guys
that you've invested,
that is the builder itself,
wakes up, and you have a tiff.
And he leaves.
Do you think that the
bank will say, oh, well,
you had a fight with the
guy, so 20 million gone.
No.
It's a financial discussion.
So two reasons-- one is
that once you prosecute one,
then the others will be careful
about adhering to the terms.
But bigger than
that was the fact
that at that time
in the industry,
many people were jumping
up and down, misbehaving.
And we wanted to set an
example because that's
what we were set up to
do, to set an example.
And I'll do it again
because what it means
is that when people see
that these copyrights are
enforceable, then they can
put the money they want to.
Very few companies-- my
company never accessed a loan.
Everything we've achieved has
been within-- all the debts
that we may owe is within
our directors, no more.
And many people-- and
in Nigerian patents,
11 years, that's
almost impossible.
You never hear of that.
But that's simply because
even if we went to the bank,
the bank would say, well,
what if your artist goes?
So it's more about
preserving the integrity
of the industry as a whole.
It's not about a personal
thing because when
he had his-- I mean, he
called me a couple of times.
Oh, let's sit down, resolve it.
And we had-- one day, I
actually came to the lawyer,
and we sat down.
Well, he didn't understand.
He just didn't understand, and
he still doesn't understand.
So for him, he feels-- I'm
sure that that many people,
there's a lot of
miseducation in Nigeria
about what intellectual
property is.
So I'll give an example.
We got an email from a
publishing company who
wants to use Femi Kuti's song.
The publishing rights
are signed with BMG.
The master rights are
signed with another label
that he signed on.
They're two distinct rights.
Though Femi Kuti
singed on it, Femi
doesn't have those
master rights.
So Femi will never say to his
label, oh, I'm angry with you.
Give me my master rights.
No.
They're clear.
So if the artist feels that
I can break this contract,
do what I want to do, and
yet be able to come back
and ask for things that
I clearly benefited
from and signed off before,
then it's not possible.
So all it was was just
saying, industry, we
need to be careful because
each time somebody breaks
his contract and
nothing happens,
less people will
invest in the industry.
And that's why you find
that in movies-- movies
have had more money
pumped into it
than music because
music is so volatile.
But it's changing.
I mean, the great
thing about that--
there's a lot of things
that are changing.
And I'm hoping that
over time, people will
begin to learn those lessons.
And that's the only way
the industry will grow.
And that's why we found out
the music industry's not
as big as it should really be.
It's simply because
the investors
are afraid of putting
their money in something
that is that volatile.
So it's not personal.
When he had his
baby, I hit him up.
But it's business.
It's business.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Are
there any other questions?
AUDU MAIKORI: Wow, that's
a really hard question.
So the other day, we
had this CNN, Twitter--
so we had an interview.
And they're asking--
so what happened
was that they were
asking questions
about the African
music industry.
And my partner and I
were kind of responding.
And then people
who were following
could also just send a question.
And one question
that they said was,
what do we do about the rapidly
declining standards of Nigerian
music and the rubbish
that they're seeing?
And I said to the person that
the music that we're listening
is a reflection of our society.
We are responsible for that.
The artist panders to
what the audience wants.
So if the audience says, we
don't want to hear this crap,
give us real music,
you will see a change.
If society says, we don't want
to see all this flash and all
this noise.
We want something that sends a
message, you will see a shift.
Because remember that
[INAUDIBLE] are providing
a "service," in quotes, not
a service in the traditional
sense.
So somebody must be buying it.
So people are buying it.
People are buying it
from how they respond.
But I think that in terms
of curbing excesses,
it's a function of the
leadership, a function
of the culture and saying--
so, for example, maybe four,
five years ago, I remember that
I really told the artist, look,
you get [INAUDIBLE], but
you will not be hot forever.
So you should start
thinking about building
your own companies.
So for many of them,
their companies
were registered by
my law firm to help
them start doing
some sort of business
or leading their own
labels because it's clear
that you will not be successful
for more than 10 years.
You could be, but
why take the risk?
So that comes in.
Guys, you need to buy land.
Don't buy a Land
Rover, buy land.
Don't buy the Rover
because you need something
to-- so sometimes they listen.
Sometimes they don't.
But when you have a figure
that they kind of listen to--
and that's why the
relationship is
important-- they may
think that, maybe he's
not just trying to be silly.
Maybe he does have my interests.
But many of these guys,
they get to a level
whereby they don't have
any advisors anymore.
And that happens with everybody.
So there's nobody that's exempt.
You get to a level
whereby you think, hmm.
Let's pop champagne
from morning till night.
They'll sell the record.
Popping champagne
from 12:00 to 6 AM.
When you've finished, you've
popped up your whole savings.
And there's nobody to say,
no, you cannot do that.
No, you cannot do that.
So I think that that is there.
And then the professionalism
level is very low, as well.
So you find that managers
are more like PAs.
So they don't give advice.
They just take instructions.
So we need to.
And over time, I
think it will change.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Great, thank you.
AUDU MAIKORI: Oh, OK.
So I think that
again, like I said,
I'm in business for a reason.
I didn't really think
that Chocolate City--
I hoped it would be successful.
But I didn't know it
would get to this.
But the whole aim of setting
it up was to make a difference
and try to empower people.
But I find that in Africa,
we have a leadership problem.
Leaders hold onto power forever.
So I was just thinking that
I've worked in probably five
companies, both local
and international.
And I found that being able to
grow-- so I'll give an example.
10 years ago, I was
company secretary
of a company called
Abuja Markets Management.
And in six months, I
had two promotions.
I was already GM,
I was acting GM,
and I was basically running--
so when the MD wasn't around,
I was basically
running the office,
I was running the staff,
maybe 50-something
or 60-something staff.
And at that time,
I'd have people
waiting at the
reception for two hours
to see me because we
were running property
stuff for the Abuja government.
And one day, I woke up, and I
said-- I think about 29 or 30
then.
And I said, I've become
an old man already
because I'm sitting
[INAUDIBLE] some guy at 31.
So I was like, so
where do I go next?
Where's the progression?
And so my next job, I moved
six months later to a company
called CPCS Transcom.
It was a Canadian firm.
And that's where I worked
in infrastructure and power
and all that stuff.
But when I was leaving, my
MD didn't want me to go.
But he said he
understood that I needed
to go because he saw
that I was too restless.
So I was thinking that
when I get to 40 years
old or before I get to 40, I
can't be doing the same thing I
was doing 10 years ago.
Where's the progression?
So five years before that, we
decided-- MI became director
in 2010 in Chocolate City.
And we gave him shares
as early as 2010.
And we're looking
at grooming somebody
who would-- so there
were three people we
were grooming, actually.
OK, who could come in
and take over this?
And I remember that when I made
the decision, people would say,
Audu, if you leave
Chocolate City,
there's going to be a problem.
Then I thought that there
is going to be a problem.
That means I've not
built Chocolate City.
I've built Audu city.
So it needed to
survive on its own.
And I needed to
take those risks.
So when I made the decision,
I was like, before I turn 40,
I'm going to hand
over this company.
And I need to build
others because there's
much more I want to do.
And that was the decision.
And I thought, they've
been there for a while.
They wanted to learn.
They'd become men.
And they were a bit older than I
was when I started the company.
So I'm sure they can handle it.
And that was it.
And I feel that
leaders in Africa
always have that
problem, it's that they
want to be chairman,
CEO forever and ever.
At 79, you're chairman and CEO.
And you were same
when you were 29.
So how are we growing
the younger generation?
How are they learning
anything if we're not
giving them responsibility?
So that was really it.
It was that decision.
It wasn't cause I'd
gotten bored with it.
It's nice to walk around
red carpets and people
taking pictures.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
I'm sure they still do.
AUDU MAIKORI: Sometimes,
but not as much.
But the idea was just let's
hand over to younger people.
They have better
ideas than we do.
They're smarter than we are,
and they have more potential.
So let's not get it twisted that
we think we're the only ones.
No.
And if African leaders
behave like that,
we'll have a better continent.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
I think you
raise a very important point
for organizations to be
sustainable, built to last.
Succession planning is
very, very important.
So it's actually great to
see that that was actually
a conscious process, grooming
people that could actually take
over at the appointed time.
Are there any other questions?
AUDU MAIKORI: OK, yeah.
So what happened was this-- in
2011, we had a conversation.
I said, are you thinking
about-- so there's
this guys called GRIP Boiz.
You guys know them.
So we're talking,
and I said, Ice,
what is happening with
these GRIP Boiz guys.
What are you doing with them?
He said, no.
They're just these guys
following up and down.
And I said, I think you should
sign them onto your label.
I think you need to create
your own label and sign.
'Cause at that time,
MI had LOOPY MUSIC.
Yeah, MI had LOOPY
MUSIC, as well.
And he missed that window.
So GRIP Boiz.
Got other management
and all that stuff.
So in 2013 or '14,
the conversation
started about him
starting his own label.
OK.
There's some things
I can't say here
because I have a press
conference on Monday.
So I can't reveal
some things about it.
But rest assured that
in that same vein,
having served one
year, it's time for him
to do his own thing.
Having been faithful and
worked all that time,
it's time for me to support him.
So he's not starting
something that's foreign.
It's that we're also
supporting and making
him independent to do that.
The same thing with Jesse Jagz.
And I think that that
is the model where--
that's how the music industry
is actually going to go anyway.
So we're just being
clairvoyant about it.
We just think that artists want
better control of what they do.
But what they need is they
need a label and structure that
helps them be better.
Remember what I said
about you're not
becoming more talented because
you signed on our label.
You have more of
a structure that
helps you to be able to
explore your talent even more.
So it's all part
of the progression
plan, which is
that everybody must
begin to grow their own bodies.
Now, in 2005, I tell
people the story
that the first
artist we signed was
a guy called Jeremiah Gyang.
And I was looking
for [INAUDIBLE]
to sign him off on to.
I would call, they would
give me the runaround.
So I got tired.
And I was like, screw it.
I'll just do it myself.
And if they had
signed him, there
would be no Chocolate
City today, probably.
So it's important that
we begin to enable people
to do their own things and build
their own visions because we
need more of those things.
Not everybody can be
signed on Chocolate City.
Not many.
So that's the same principle.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: OK.
Was there another question?
AUDU MAIKORI: Lyrical content?
You know, again, these are
the issues of regulation
and the market that determines
some of these things.
I'll be honest.
I've seen some of the videos.
And I get worried when the kids
are around because I'm like,
they shouldn't be twerking.
They shouldn't be saying,
you chop my money.
I don't mean that in reference--
I'm just saying, those things,
they shouldn't be
saying those things
because there's
something about music
that people don't understand.
Music is a spiritual experience
beyond any other experience
in the world.
I believe this happened
to you-- you've
heard some songs that you know
you've never heard before.
But when you hear
them, you thought
you've heard them before.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Yes.
AUDU MAIKORI: And I came up
with a theory, the Audu theory.
You can google it.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
The Audu theory.
AUDU MAIKORI: You can google it.
But my theory is that
children in the womb
listen to what their
parents are listening.
Right?
So as they're playing
the music, the child
is subconsciously hearing
it, and in some way,
hitting your brain
cells somewhere.
So when you hear the
music, it's something
that your mother heard before.
The point I'm trying
to make is that when
a child is hearing those
things over and over again,
it's ingrained in their mind.
And one day, it will come up.
And when it comes up,
it comes up negatively.
So I am worried about that.
And what we try do in Chocolate
City is be careful about that.
We always try to
be very-- in fact,
I know that there was a fight.
We had one artist where
they had a album cover,
and it was something.
And I said, no.
We had a big fight over it.
I said, no.
I'm not gonna allow that.
You can go do it
on your own thing,
but don't do it
on my thing simply
because I think that the
music needs to be sellable.
And guess what?
The best, most popular
songs are the songs
that everybody can
listen to and can enjoy.
So you're right, but
how do you do that?
The NBC has a explicit
content regulation.
So if a song is too lewd or
it has too many whatever,
they'll ban the
video and all that.
But the problem with that is
that MTV will still play it,
and children are on DStv.
So don't let them watch DStv.
But, I mean, over time,
hopefully that will change.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Any other question?
OK.
So bringing it back to
your-- looking at what
really drives you.
I read one of your
articles tied to-- well,
it started with, I'm angry.
AUDU MAIKORI: It's
title "I Am Angry."
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Titled "I Am Angry," as well.
OK.
And it was very passionate,
very heartfelt, right?
And it was a challenge
to young people in terms
of their roles in
society and how
they use technology platforms
like social media, et cetera.
And also, you were a key member
of the Enough Is Enough rally
just addressing governance
issues in Nigeria.
What's your motivation?
And what's your dream
as a young Nigerian?
AUDU MAIKORI: Not so young.
Not so young Nigerian.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Well, well.
AUDU MAIKORI: But I
just think that when
you look at what Nigeria could
have been and what we are,
we know that we're a far
cry from the promised land.
And we have not
learned that it is not
by doing the same thing by
the same people over and over
that we get different results.
There's a whole
theory about that.
It's called madness.
And I really understand
why the older generation
behaved the way they behave.
These are guys that
came from the villages.
They didn't know
what electricity was.
They woke up, and the
white man was somewhere,
and they started going
to missionary schools.
Then they graduated and
went aboard and schooled.
Then they came back and
started running their country.
You understand.
So they struggled
for all those things.
And because of that, they've
clutched onto those things
because that is what
they think they have.
And then we have a
couple young people
who are brilliant, intelligent.
They're doing fantastic things.
The best stories you
hear about Nigeria
are about the younger generation
now, not the older generation.
It is the innovation.
It is the creativity.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
Entrepreneurship.
AUDU MAIKORI: The
entrepreneurs, the people
that are innovating and
changing the landscape.
But they do not understand
that whatever they do
is actually limited by what the
powers that be say they can do.
So you remember the
social media bill which
just rested in peace recently.
But there was a hole
uproar about that.
And because there was nobody
influential right there,
it even had its day in the sun.
It shouldn't have.
But it's because
the people who have
the brains, the
intelligence, the passion
are not interested in that.
They'd rather do nine-to-fives
and start businesses.
That is not bad.
But we can't all
do the same thing.
And I also felt that
for a long time,
politics has been demonized.
So people just say,
oh, he's a politician.
It's a dirty game.
You know?
And holier than thou.
But even if you're not
playing the dirty game,
the dirt is being
poured upon you.
So what are you
going to do about it?
And I just thought that
instead of blaming, oh,
why do we not have this?
It's because the young
people are not interested.
They've lost hope.
So mine was a call to action and
saying, we must change things.
We must take responsibility
for the future of this country.
We can't keep blaming our
fathers for what they did.
Our fathers have done
their own-- my father
is 74 years old.
He's not the man he used to be.
But he's great.
He's lived a great life.
Now, whatever happens in
Nigeria is not his business
because he can die anytime.
But he's lived his life.
So it's now about the
future generation.
So it's not really
a call about us.
It's a call about our children.
It's that we need to
leave this country better
than we lived through.
But in our case, our
parents lived a better life
than we are.
Right?
Our parents lived
in a better Nigeria
than we are living currently.
So it'll only be wicked for us
to leave a worse-off Nigeria
for our kids.
So it only makes sense for
us to do something about it.
And the only way
we can do that is
get involved in making those
political decisions that
affect our economy,
our livelihood,
our social well-being.
So that's where that came from.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
And you announced recently
that you are looking to
get involved in politics.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
I was going to ask you
the question, why now?
But I think you've sort
of answer it already,
the motivation behind that.
But what I'll say
is you mentioned
that there are a number
of people that stay away.
I think part of the
motivation behind that
might just be just
a sense of it's
very hard to break through.
I may have to compromise
in certain ways for me
to be able to sit at the
table, that sort of thing.
What's your view, and
how does that play out
in terms of your own ambition?
AUDU MAIKORI: I feel
that we make compromises
every single day.
We make compromises on
different levels every day.
So I think that someone will
call it cafeteria Christianity.
So you go in and say, oh, I
want to have some of this.
No, I'm not going to
have some of this.
You pick what you
think is compromise.
We all compromise everyday.
I'm not saying be unethical.
I'm saying that every
game has its rules.
So if you're playing handball
and you kick the ball in,
it is not a goal.
Right?
Unless it is football.
So politics has its own rules.
We can either rewrite the
rules or we can play the rules
until we get to a position
where we can change those rules.
And what I'm saying is that
for a long time, the people who
have controlled the
conversation are
people who are A, not
particularly educated, B, not
particularly patriotic.
But one thing they
understood is that we
keep close to the people.
So they're having
conversation with the people
over a period of time, and
they make them promises.
They have no vision.
They have only a mission,
and their mission
is to plunder and to
reward one or two people.
So the visionaries are
there sitting down,
complaining every day
about the problem.
So I'm saying that that
conversation has to change.
Now, how does affect the people
that have been away from it
for a while?
And how do you get immersed?
I think that politics is not
a function of just running
for election.
It's about how economic
and social decisions
are being made every day.
So there's politics
even in Google, right?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
In homes--
AUDU MAIKORI: Is that
politically correct?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Well, yes.
AUDU MAIKORI: But no, no.
But there's politics--
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: In
homes, even, in families.
AUDU MAIKORI: No, there's
politics in everything.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
An integral part of life.
AUDU MAIKORI: Politics
is the discussion
of how power is shared,
our resources are shared.
That's all.
So it may not be
that your running.
And I'm saying that it starts
from one action to the other
to the other.
You need to start taking
small actions in our society
and hope-- not even hope.
When the government sees that
this whole thing is happening,
they'll come and say, OK.
So how can we work with you?
How can we make this happen?
And that is what
I'm talking about.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: I think
certainly, a lot of Nigerians
have a very big vision
for the country.
I think we're all united
in the understanding
and the perception
that where we are
is far from the promise
that really exists
because we know Nigerians are
talented, resilient, and so on.
And I think we're all united
in our optimism for a greater
future.
AUDU MAIKORI: Yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Talking about the future,
the next 10 years for Chocolate
Group, what does that look
like?
For you and for
Chocolate City Group.
AUDU MAIKORI: There's
a lot we're doing.
But we're focused on
building infrastructure now.
We think that there needs to
be some more expansion in terms
of the infrastructure that
helps the entertainment
industry grow.
So we're running a few projects.
Because of the nature
of the projects,
I can't talk to you about that.
But one of the projects
we're working on
is a media city, which
is going to be in Kaduna.
We're wrapping up that
conversation, as well.
We're working on some
property development,
as well, in Abuja,
which will have
performance venues and
production and things
like that.
In Lagos, we are also ruling
out a distribution platform,
as well.
We are part of--
so two years ago,
we launched something
called [INAUDIBLE] Music.
It basically aggregates content.
But it's beyond Chocolate City.
It's SPV.
Because we also believe
strongly in partnership.
So the rule I really play
in Chocolate City now
is more of the partnership guy.
My job is to look for those
strategic partnerships
because I know that together,
we can do it much better.
And that's what you'll see.
You'll see the film part
of Chocolate City, as well.
By 2017 for sure, our
first movie will be out.
But beyond that, we are
thinking about churning
a whole slew of contents.
So that's what it looks like.
JULIET EHIMUAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
AUDU MAIKORI: And more
people, stronger team,
get more people employed.
In East Africa, we're just kind
of reconstituting the board
because we're trying to
be a bit more effective.
East Africa is
actually now picking up
at a very interesting rate.
And so we've been there
for three years now.
We're trying to reposition
to make sure that we're
carried along on that wave.
So that's what it looks like.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
We'll definitely
be watching this space,
looking out for the movie
when it comes out next
year and watching out
to see all the other
projects unfold.
AUDU MAIKORI: And literally, it
will be exclusively on YouTube.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Wooho!
AUDU MAIKORI: Just the trailer.
Just the trailer.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Thank you so much, Audu,
for spending this time with us.
It's been great having
you at the office
and having this
conversation with you.
Thanks for making the time.
AUDU MAIKORI: It's--
before you clap,
it's been very enriching
talking to you guys.
And I want to say
thank you to Google.
You guys are great.
Very beautiful office.
But more importantly, you have
beautiful officers and people
who are helping to train and
to pass skills to many people.
My company has benefited
immensely from that.
Many other companies have.
And I want to commend
the job you're doing.
And I wish you guys more
success, more blessing,
more bandwidth, literally.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Thank you.
AUDU MAIKORI: To keep
doing what you're doing.
So thank you very much.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Thank you very much, Audu.
Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]